هذه الفتره ليست الوحيده التي يستشري فيها
الفساد في اوكرانيا هي ظاهره طبيعيه في
كييف منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وقتها
ترك الجيش السوبياتي كميه كبيره من
الاسلحه في اوكرانيا دون الاحتفاظ
بالسجلات الكافيه والنتيجه جزء من مخزون
الاسلحه الصغيره للجيش الاوكرانيه التي
تجاوز عام 1992 7 ملايين قطعه وصل الى
مناطق النزاع حول العالم الامر ذاته يتكرر
الان والانتربول من ذلك ليس فقط من
الانتشار في البلدان المجاوره لكن ايضا
للقارات الاخرى وصلنا الى العام 2014 قبل
الهجوم الروسيه على القرم والفساد لا يزال
موجوده
حتى في صناعه الدفاع الاوكرانيه الامر
الذي ساهم في اضعاف قدره الجيش على التصدي
لهجوم
بعد هذه الازمه برزت اهميه مكافحه الفساد
تشكلت شبكه عامه ومكتب وطني في صفوف الجيش
والاجهزه المدنيه لكن القرارات لم تفلح في
تجنب السيناريوم مشابه قبل الحرب الاخيره
نحو 30% من ميزانيه الدفاع كانت مفقوده
بسبب قصور بما في ذلك الفساد تفشي الفساد
في اوكرانيا كان عاقبه اصلا العام الماضي
في طريق سعيك للانضمام الاتحاد الاوروبي
احتلت عام 2021 المرتبه المئه واثنت 220
من الاصلي 180 في مؤشر الفساد الخاص منظمه
الشفافيه الدوليه